welcome back to new rock stars
spider-man no way home second trailer is
likely coming soon and we just got new
details from the set that have hinted
that peter parker could leave this
universe forever but it's not about
where he leaves from it's about where he
is going and where we're going we don't
need whips what don't need flips
impossible
i don't know what that means i just
wanted to sound cool
this is inside marvel our weekly deep
dive into the biggest marvel news i'm
eric voss i'm here with mt how you doing
empty i'm feeling good i'm feeling good
spider-man coming soon new trailer dude
i need it i need it in my blood stream
that first trailer wasn't enough not
enough never enough
so this week on inside marvel we're
going to be talking about spider-man no
way home the new stuff that we've
learned but also a bit later in the show
why did marvel shift its 2022-2023
release schedule we have answers and at
the end of the episode i'm going to give
you my non-spoiler review of eternals
because i was so fortunate to be invited
to lucky dog look at that lucky duck
over there everybody he knows too much
i know too much it's hard not to talk
about but you know it's not too hard to
not freaking spoil the post-credit
scenes right what's wrong with you
it's a minefield out there don't get
spoiled seriously stay off twitter if
you can just stay out twitter if you can
i think that's the only answer i don't
know how to how to avoid it at this
point before we talk about all that head
on over to newrockstarsmerch.com to grab
yourself one of our latest obsession
shirts inspired by shanghi uh these are
limited edition supply shirts uh we are
serious about that the shirts inspired
by what if are already sold out they're
gone forever so you better jump on this
one quick if you can and we're gonna
have some designs for eternals coming
out soon that uh i can't wait to
announce with all you guys and the cool
thing is if you buy one of these latest
obsession shirts you'll get the option
to write in a custom shout out that will
run along the bottom of the screen
during inside marvel let's see what we
got here
uh
hey glad to finally catch up on some of
your merch this from rob what if venom
briefly bonds with peter in no way home
i personally don't think that will
happen i think that will happen in a
future title
um i think there's just too much and no
way home i think a little i think a
little bit of venom might bond onto
peter but not the whole thing yeah yeah
yeah i think they might like exist there
might be a sighting or a reference to
them but i don't think he's going to
like fuse to him yeah mark says you help
my daughter discover her inner nerd and
it's amazing yay i love hearing stuff
like that hooray for your
daughter um welcome one of us one of us
and then sean says the verticals of
every axis in the multiverse meet at
gamma delta four one five what
uh
i hope i'll take your word for it
okay so what's our our big question this
week mt well eric where is spider-man
going after no way home yeah so the cast
of spider-man no way home just did an
interview with entertainment weekly
which historically tends to precede a
trailer release so
let's all be on the lookout for a
spider-man no way honestly
i'm paranoid eric i'm paranoid i know
i have me too me too but there was a lot
of interesting quotes but this one from
tom holland stood out to me he said we
were all treating no way home as the end
of a franchise let's say i think if we
were lucky enough to dive into these
characters again you'd be seeing a very
different version it would no longer be
the homecoming trilogy
we would give it some time and try to
build something different and tonally
change the films whether that happens or
not i don't know we were definitely
treating no way home like it was coming
to an end and it felt like it we've been
making these films for five years now
we've had such an amazing relationship
the three of us we've been with each
other every step of the way we've done
every single film every single press
tour so this one scene we didn't know if
this would be the last time we were all
working together
so some interesting ideas there right
the idea that the homecoming trilogy is
coming to an end but perhaps a new
trilogy going forward or just a new
series but here's what we know for sure
tom holland has at least one more
spider-man movie in his contract right
so back in september of 2019 sony and
disney came to that new contract that
they were signing for how they were
going to share the spider-man character
uh and that deal was for tom to be in a
third sony spider-man title and that's
what no way home is right and then uh in
addition to that he should appear in
another big mcu crossover title like
what end game and infinity war and civil
war were that may not be the case for
zendaya or jacob battle on i think
that's what he was saying like we don't
know if the three of us are gonna be in
one of these movies together again uh
but that might mean that tom holland's
next marvel role is gonna separate him
from this universe of friends and
transport him somewhere else in the
multiverse in my mind i see two
directions of what this next big
crossover film could be i think in tom
holland's mind he hopes and would assume
that peter parker will be exploring a
series beyond that but there is
something else on the horizon
and i see that as one of two options one
avengers 5 which i think could be super
wars like transport them to battle world
i think that's the most exciting option
i see hell
yeah know it that would involve
multiversal incursions to get everyone
someplace
um or it could be a bit more grounded
and just remove peter parker from his
world of characters and bring him in
with the fantastic four because we know
john watts after spider-man no way home
is going to be directing fantastic four
for the mcu and we know that is in
pre-production
so which one do you think is more likely
do we think p and which one's more
exciting you know i could make an
argument in either case to see peter
parker team up with like a younger reed
richards oh yeah hell yeah and like i've
been dying to see the dynamic between
between peter parker and johnny storm
for so long because they would just get
i love their dynamic of the comics and
like it would be hilarious in a
fantastic four film but in terms of like
which one of these are more likely
i think that
more likely a fantastic four team up
however
and a secret wars uh appearance does
seem more likely on a contractual basis
so on a narrative basis i feel like
fantastic four but on a contractual
basis secret wars because like you said
with the multiverse and like in the this
multiversal direction that marvel is
going so i think that at the end of no
way home we're going to see peter just
be removed from his universe and i think
that we see peter removed from his
universe in the trailer i think that
that's personally i think that's what's
happening is that sure is that uh doctor
strange and peter have moved themselves
from the mcu to an mcu adjacent uh very
similar universe where wild things are
gonna happen and so i think at the end
of this movie peter parker and you know
you're totally not in this movie andrew
garfield and
toby mcguire are probably might have
their own trilogy of spider-verse
multiversal films and so like they're
going to do their own thing in their
spider-verse and then we might get a new
like miles morales
in the mcu trilogy while they're off
doing their own thing so i think that
for that final peter parker
film um that he has in his contract is
going to be this huge multiversal event
that is going to tie in everything from
your from your loki's to whatever
they're doing with you know the
multiverse on the ant-man three side of
things everything's gonna come together
on the spider verse the venomverse into
this one huge avengers secret wars
scenario but what do you what do you
think yeah i i think you're right um uh
i'm very curious to see what john watts
is gonna do with fantastic four oh yes
um i i think marvel would probably get
more value out of having peter parker at
the heart of a secret wars event because
fantastic four you want them to be the
stars of it and any time you put
spider-man in a movie he is the star of
that
movie so 100
right and i would imagine that avengers
secret wars would be a ripe opportunity
for marvel to use peter parker the way
that they used iron man for end game
where he was able to make the sacrifice
play like in secret wars you could make
uh tom holland spider-man the star of
that movie even though he's not in the
title of it it still would kind of feel
like a spider-man movie that he gets to
be leading the charge up he could be the
tip of that spear who ends up going out
in this like heartbreaking way that
we're all ready to say goodbye and then
maybe he cameos in the future like that
could be his i am spider-man moment you
know
um where he like saves us all and i
think you're right i think miles morales
in live action is really the future move
for at least sony and i think marvel's
gonna want to arrange some kind of deal
where miles morales can exist in the mcu
and interact with all those other
characters they already kind of have
that going with miles does technically
exist in the mcu with uh with donald
glover as aaron davis his uncle aaron
saying mentioning that he has a nephew
miles somewhere which is a weird thing
to bring up in conversation i got a
nephew that lives around here okay i
don't know you for sure
yeah i don't like weapons because i got
a nephew that lives around here a little
forest but
yeah like we all got different i was
like
yeah so i don't care um but yeah so i
think that would be uh where i would
hope marvel goes i mean honestly at the
end of the day why not both right i love
i would love a fantastic four movie
where even if we just see johnny storm
at college and then like the roommate
next door is making a lot of noise he
knocks on the door and peter parker goes
oh sorry and the room is covered with
webbing
just a quick cameo like a quick like uh
you know evan peters and deadpool 2
style yeah that'd be so great i love
when they do stuff like that i think
that's where things are going just
because i don't i it makes sense to me
that there's gonna be some scene and no
way home where the three friends are
kind of coming to an end because we
can't just keep doing that forever as
much as new rock stars would be happy to
have that be the case
you know um but i i think ultimately
they're gonna have to start to
uh evolve things and transform things
and here's our opportunity with the
multiverse blowing open to go in
completely new directions well eric i
got a question for you how likely do you
feel that a young avengers situation
could happen with with spider-man
because throughout this entire
homecoming trilogy it's always been like
oh you're the new iron man you're the
new like who's gonna leave the avengers
and all this stuff so like and we do
have all these young avengers slowly
assembling and the most experienced
young avenger even though technically
spider-man has never been a young
avenger in the comics it is still peter
parker and like i feel like it would
make sense for him to lead this young
avengers team that you know in their
original forming was very much in this
multiversal timeline crossing thing with
their interactions with iron lad which
is a younger version of kang so maybe we
could see a multiversal little young
avengers movie or project with peter
parker leading these young avengers
through i don't know timelines and i
don't know just sort of making it sort
of like a spider-verse mcu multiverse
adjacent project
yeah
as fun as that would be and as logical
as that seems to be as him just being a
younger character who is an avenger
i think uh peter parker's too big of a
title to like he i believe he would
overshadow the other members of the
young avengers to me the most exciting
version of the young avengers and mcu
going forward is one that is a kang
origin story just because what jonathan
majors has given us as by playing kang
and loki is such an exciting opportunity
and i think
right now for a lot of people they're
like oh so just kid of it people who
haven't uh been familiar with the
younger members of the comics they're
like so i'm just gonna see like muppet
babies but with adventures playhouse
disney avengers okay yeah they don't
they don't want that um but it doesn't
have to be that these are i think we'll
know a lot more coming out of hawkeye
with kate bishop right and i think
ant-man the was quantum mania it's going
to give us some information when it
comes to stature and with kang as a
character i i see a young avengers as a
kang adjacent title than the spider-man
adjacent title but i think it would
really help that lineup if you could
include like miles morales or gwen stacy
in that kind of lineup
it complicates what they can do with
young avengers because those are all
sony properties right they can't just
put out a disney plus series called
young avengers if you need a spider
thing to be part of it unfortunately
well we're gonna discuss why marvel is
delaying all these 2022 and 2023 titles
we've been talking about but first
thanks to our friends at bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode guys there's
nothing sexier than confidence and blue
chew can help give you that confidence
where it counts blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets in a diffraction
of the cost you can take them anytime
day or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises and
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you will receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting line the
pharmacy blue juice tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help you and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code insidemarvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode we also want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode we all sometimes
lose sleep binging a show or debating
our loved ones over something from the
latest disney plush show but you
shouldn't lose any sleep because of a
bad mattress helix sleep is a quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down to be sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress i love it the quiz
match me with a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support that sleeps cool the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
or anything just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you'll get to try
it out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will love it helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
insidemarvel and we want to thank
upstart for sponsoring this episode we
can all wonder if we'd be worthy of
wielding mjolnir but one thing we don't
have to wonder about is whether we're
credit worthy and again thanks to our
friends at upstart upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income your
employment history this means that they
can offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a 5 minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you loan amounts we need to determine
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel all
right mt let's get back to our big
marvel news this week well eric why
did marvel delay its 22 slash you know
2023 titles because like that was a huge
thing that happened the other day and i
was very upset yeah so uh let's get to
the details here disney announced in a
press release on monday that they're
rescheduling their upcoming titles each
by a few months let's actually show the
graphic here so doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness moved from march
25th to may 6 2022 411 thunder moved
from may 6 to july 8 2022 black panther
wakanda forever moved from july 8th to
november 11th 2022 captain marvel 2 aka
the marvels moved from november 11th to
february 17th 2023 ant-man and the wasp
quantomania moved from february 2023 to
july 8 2023 guardians of the galaxy vol
3 is staying at may 5th 2023 and uh now
the cast has been locked james gunn has
begun production on it this week they
also removed the other titles that were
previously scheduled for july 8 2023 and
october 6 2023 but then moved up the
unannounced title in november 2023 to
november 3rd 2023 we don't know what
that movie will be yet we got plenty of
guesses though for most of these titles
the delay ranges from like six weeks to
a few months and it's not that big of a
deal ultimately like we're still getting
three to four mcu movies per year with
weekly disney plus series episodes in
between there's gonna be so much to
watch and talk about we're spoiled right
now we're getting like no i'm just so
spoiled i'm just like oh man oh a few
months of delay darn it but like we've
been so blessed so i need to yeah i
think it's going to be fine it's going
to be fine but the question still is why
are they doing this uh reportedly this
has nothing to do with concerns over the
openness of cinemas throughout 2022 i
think disney's pretty confident they'll
still do theatrical releases for all
this stuff and i don't think marvel is
afraid of sharing a month with the
batman if anything they would be bullish
about going head to head with a dc title
because we saw them do that with the
marvels opening a week before dc's the
flash in november so yeah it's gonna be
fine but interestingly at the eternals
premiere red carpet last night an event
that i was also at but i did not
had to watch it witness
twitter later like one else did uh kevin
feige downplayed all of this as you know
production shifts and changes he's kind
of like look it's just six weeks you
know
but what does production shifts and
changes mean like which production is
shifting which production is causing
this
well let's look at the multiverse of
madness is wrapped and i think is in
little danger of missing its picture
lock deadline in early march i think
they're on schedule i think we would
have heard more they've had plenty of
time to work on this movie you know yeah
it's been a while now and i think the
same for thor love and thunder but we
have heard very little about black
panther wakanda forever compared to
these other titles and i think of all of
these 2022 films this one is getting the
most significant delay of four months
from july to november and i think that
makes sense with all the work ryan
coogler's having to do to reconfigure
the script it sounds like from page one
so yeah it makes sense that they're
gonna need some extra time on the back
end of shooting that movie and getting
it right but i also think it's possible
that ant-man the wasp quantum mania
jumping from february 2023 all the way
to july 2023 that's a big shift and i
think it's because they now see this
title as an even bigger event with
jonathan majors as kang crushing it and
loki and i think
they want that to be a big summer
release
and maybe to give themselves the whole
first half of the year in 2023 to
release a loki season 2
to explore kang more as a character
what do you think empty
that is probably very likely to be a
factor here because like you know they
had no idea that people were going to
love jonathan major so much i'm sure
they had an idea because they were there
watching yeah
do that and like see see they're seeing
it in real time on the set so they knew
that there was going to be something
special but like i just feel like the
the reception was like crazy amazing and
people loved it so much and like they
just blew it out of the park with the
actual finished product with editing
that like it's just like yeah we're all
hyped for jonathan majors as gang i feel
like they might be just rewriting that
script like all right let's just let's
just put a little more kang in here like
let's hang it up it's not it's not too
dangerous uh sorry i'm gonna do i'm done
with the cake never apologize
is that dangerous enough yeah i mean uh
there could be some other like maybe the
maybe the vfx work on multiverse of
madness needs six extra weeks i don't
think so i think they'll be able to get
it all done um yeah i think it's either
wakanda forever or
quantum mania they want some time to do
some more world building like it's
possible they want to fit in a young
avengers series in the first half of
2023 as well that explores nathaniel
richards as a boy you know um i i just
think ultimately they
realize they'll make more money if that
movie releases in the summer than if it
releases in february uh and they feel
confident in it it's also possible that
like they want to precede the marvels
with a secret invasion series and then
they need that to release late in 2022
uh i think that's what he means by
production shifts i think it's just
somewhere in there and they're like we
don't need multiverse of madness to rush
out and uh march we're gonna make a crap
ton of money from eternals so that will
carry us over through the first quarter
i think we'll be okay let's let's just
swing away at that one in may yeah man i
i definitely do feel like this these
delays will be in our best interest at
the end of the day i definitely feel
like we're just gonna get better
products a better story being told like
that maybe the disney plush shows will
coordinate better with the release of
the movies to get us more excited just
trust in papa kevin papa kevin knows
that's good and guys trust me
eternals is just a few weeks away that
movie's gonna give you a lot to talk
about and uh and then a couple weeks
after eternals we'll have like a marvel
disney plus day where they're gonna
announce all the stuff uh that's gonna
be coming out on disney plus throughout
2022. i'm so excited
i'm gonna share now my non-spoiler
review for eternals but in just a moment
because first we want to thank adam and
eve for sponsoring this episode adam and
eve has been helping folks have a good
time in the bedroom for 50 years that's
multiple generations of freakiness
they've got a huge selection of toys of
the adult variety massage oil even some
naughty board games that you can play
with your significant other they also
sell lingerie that you could definitely
fashion in some very scandalous cosplay
this halloween season adamandeve.com is
offering 50 off just about any item plus
free shipping on your entire order so
what do you have to do to get your fifty
percent off one item and free shipping
it's not hard well it will be
i was thinking the same thing
low hanging fruit tastes even more sweet
uh and uh all you gotta do is just go to
adamandeve.com and select any one item
it could be an adventurous new toy
anything you desire just enter offer
code marvel at checkout and you'll get
fifty percent off almost any item go to
adamandeve.com
two days select one item and get fifty
50 off including free shipping when you
enter offer code marvel that's
m-a-r-v-e-l-marvel
adamandeve.com all right mt what's next
all right eric you gotta tell us what is
your non-spoiler review for eternals
completely non-spoiler yeah what uh this
is such a rare opportunity this is the
first time anyone from new rockstars has
been invited to like the opening night
screening where they invite all the big
influencers and uh and youtubers and
twitter people and so i got to pump
shoulders with a bunch of people i've
been seeing online uh over the past
couple years and i was like wow it's
it's weird to see you in person and uh
they're all so nice and it was just fun
to like talk with these people in person
after a movie you know uh it's i forgot
how cool that is you know where it's
just like what did we just watch like
that was what did you think about that
that was crazy right
um
and uh there was a
bit of a debate like some interesting
mixed opinions some hot takes i could
say for myself without spoiling anything
i genuinely enjoyed eternals uh i think
it has some of the most impressive scale
that i've ever seen in an mcu film
and
all the the world building concepts are
just so well thought out and presented
uh the celestials look freaking amazing
yes
uh now i have to tell you guys i'm
someone who loves films like 2001 a
space odyssey and contact you know i
bring up these movies constantly uh
interstellar uh tree of life you know i
love it when movies just kind of depart
uh an intimate setting and just go out
into the cosmos
that's just my kind of story i love the
version of prometheus that is in my head
not the one we actually got as much
so coming from that place i really
really dig eternal's ambition and really
the way it completely reframes the mcu
and everything that we thought that we
knew
and
uh i'm also like a big drama nerd um i
minored in theater in college that's how
i spent all my time in high school was
just like pouring through old plays and
uh this film at its heart is really a
classic greek drama and in those kind of
stories you have the gods the immortals
uh or the eternals in this case but uh
immortal characters just debating
whether or not to intervene in mortal
affairs i love that kind of debate i
think it's so interesting
uh so i've always loved this kind of
story i am so happy to see chloe zhao
tackle it
under the marvel studios uh masthead uh
and i hope you all love it too however i
don't expect this movie to please every
marvel fan okay so you know when i
thought about this as i was driving home
i'm like you know i've talked to a lot
of people who watched stanley kubrick's
2001 space odyssey and thought what the
[ __ ] am i watching
[Laughter]
why is this movie on an afi top 100
movies and i get it i i get it you know
these movies are meant to be game
changing and kind of paradigm shattery
and if you watch it on some like dinky
amc screen in your hometown
it might not speak to you that's why i
say watch this on the closest thing to
an imax that you can't have this music
death in you as you're watching it i i
think it needs to be seen that way if
you're watching a movie about these like
skyscraper celestials you gotta watch it
big go big or go home mommy come on uh
and it really will pay off the bigger
screen you see it on it's not a perfect
film like i think
some of the stuff gets lost in
translation for example the super
heroics they definitely have their
moments but as a marvel film you want to
see the powers coolly executed that's
what iron man introduced in the 2008
film it's just cool to watch these
people's gear or their tech or their
thwippiness or their doctor strange
spells or uh or their black panther suit
or whatever it is like applied in badass
ways and this movie does have its
moments but a lot of it i'll say does
feel a little on the underwhelming side
like i personally don't find all the
eternals powers all that interesting to
watch and battle i don't think that's
this movie's priority at the end of the
day ultimately i could watch gilgamesh
slap the [ __ ] out of a deviant repeat
that is awesome to watch each character
gets like one really cool applause
moment so i think you know it satisfies
that but like kingo's finger guns
i don't know it just kind of feels like
a joke that the movie
isn't itself in on well those aren't the
guns that we got to be focusing on on uh
kamel nanjiani yeah we got three right
right right right
exactly right
like camille's great in this movie and
he shines uh bringing in uh all of his
uh his one-liners there's some lines
where like he clearly improvised
something that is when he's not
off-screen he's just in the background
whining about something and it's so
funny
but the finger guns it's like because
they had to do so much vfx stuff and
because it felt like there was a
misconnect between uh the vfx artists
who were having the energy blast coming
from his fingers and what camille was
often doing he does have one really
freaking cool moment though i don't want
to spoil it
but i think one of the things i was
struggling with as i was watching is at
times some of the cast seems to struggle
a little bit to connect with the whole
greek drama debate at the heart of the
film
uh that's not the case for alden like
barry kyoen crushes it in this movie uh
and he seems to be someone who just kind
of has this innate ability to
internalize really really big themes
with just little micro deliveries that
he does and i think i would have loved
to see ten shakespearean trained
aficionados uh or even like i was
thinking as i was driving home like the
cast of succession i'm obsessed with the
show succession
i think all of them it's like the best
cast on tv right now give it to them
and if they were doing eternals it would
be fascinating
okay so weird uh but awesome to see some
of those actors try to do this um but i
think ultimately it's just a tall order
to ask of most of the big movie stars
working in hollywood to be able to
convey thousands of years of grief and
life experiences in a single beat it's
just really hard to do i don't know how
i would do it uh
what does that resume look like it's
like do you have a thousand years of
grief please come on in with audition
i mean marvel's trying to do so many
things with this lineup of 10 people you
know they're trying to serve so many
different masters and it's a marvel
superhero movie you need star power you
need diversity you need comic relief and
all those things are really really
important um so to also expect all of
them to have like
decades of training who could play these
really weird gods
you know like it's a lot to ask for and
i was thinking like who could who could
have pulled this off and then i started
to think well like tilda swinton oscar
isaac jeffrey wright i'm like oh they're
already all in the emcee they're already
other characters
uh so i was thinking like you would need
someone like keanu or like yeah yeah
abdulmateen search ronin viola davis i
think that guy from squid game lee
jung-jae you know like there are the
people out there but like i get it
they're in high demand you know yeah um
and hopefully they're in talks to play
other characters that you've seen like
kiaru needs to be in the mcu tennis
absolutely like come on come on
um but i think at the end of the day i
went in this movie praying for celestial
driven mythology in mc world building
and man oh man empty this movie delivers
in spades
uh it's so freaking cool to watch what
they do and the layers of history they
unfold and and the new rules they
establish uh and there are some things
that get revealed in this movie where i
was like
like oh this is i'm gonna need some time
to digest this did they just do that
do they really just say this is a this
is mcu oh my god yes i love those
moments those are the best kinds of
moments of the mcu yeah oh yeah and uh
man there are some post-credits scenes
some of the most exciting twists i have
ever seen following an mc movie but of
course i'm not going to spoil them do
not ask me on twitter to confirm or deny
anything
just don't like i'm sorry if you were on
twitter and you saw something just
assume everything's a lie until you see
the movie seriously i'm genuinely sorry
there are some [ __ ] who have already
been tweeting it and reporting it as if
you know as if this is scoopworthy news
uh they really did ruin some things for
some people and ruin things for people
like us who
are lucky to get invited to see this
stuff early and to have that privilege
and now i don't know if disney's ever
gonna let
you know press see this again early or
they might do what sony uh did and and
show us a version of the film that
doesn't have the post credits scenes
attached to it which would be a shame
because that is such a big part of the
joy as you're walking out of a theater
um but i cannot believe i cannot believe
people claim to be major reporters and
critics came out of that movie waited
one minute past the social media embargo
and immediately tweeted a spoiler it's
so frustrating to see that and i hope
those people are blacklisted and are
never allowed to report on anything
that's just journalism without integrity
bro like people trust sources like you
know that will not be named to you know
be reliable and to not spoil things like
spoilers are not news that's the yeah
you just exactly spoiler isn't a scoop
yeah right yeah it's not news
right and these people knew how this
would be spread on social media uh it
was it's a shame to see and to be clear
i'm not naming them out of respect of
them i'm not naming them because i don't
want people to go find them on twitter
and see what they said right like just
don't like just don't let your curiosity
stay buried for just a couple more weeks
uh like i had seen some rumors uh that
people tweeted me before ice before
monday night and i just discounted all
of them you know uh but there were
specific details about the rumors that i
hadn't even heard of before
that i got to see and it was such a cool
feeling to be genuinely surprised uh in
those moments so just trust me trying to
be a rough two weeks man it's gonna be
rough
you can do it i believe in you uh and
i'll be there with you guys on november
5th i'm going to go back there opening
or november 4th whatever the thursday
night screening is i'm going to be there
i'm going to be at amc burbank uh i want
you guys all to be there with me i'm
going to be cheering this movie i can't
wait to rewatch it uh and as you guys
see it what i'm going to be paying
attention to even more is the music like
listen closely ramin jawadi is the game
of thrones composer he's the westworld
composer he does some really cool stuff
with organ like it's like interstellar
organ [ __ ] is going on he uses during
one battle scene like an electric
upright base like
like it just sounds really cool i don't
know
it might just be upright bass played
like a rock guitar i i don't know
how it's done i am a sucker for a good
superhero movie soundtrack like i
literally view superhero movies as music
videos for the mute like for the the
soundtrack so like i'm so excited it's
my favorite score since um since what uh
ludwig joranson did for black panther my
panther oh my god that's high praise
because that man is a god that man is
like a music god so wow i mean it's not
silvestri did uh infinity war and end
game uh and then i can't remember what
the scores really were for ant-man the
wasp or black widow or i mean nothing
against any of the other composers who
do marvel films this one just really
connected with me uh and it was just
really fun to watch um so watch this
movie on the biggest screen that you can
it is an epic
uh and let me know your thoughts on it
after you see it but no spoilers um
that's it for this episode yeah before
not before after um and uh and then
after this movie comes out november 5th
we're gonna be talking about it a lot
all right so this is this is just what
we do we're like don't expect us to give
this movie like a month-long spoiler
window
because everyone in the world is going
to be talking about this on november 5th
and we're going to start that
conversation
um so that's it for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i will be back
every wednesday to answer whatever your
biggest marvel questions are don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow mt at
mastertainment follow new rockstars and
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we'll see you next week everybody
[Music]
you